هنعمل ايه في الكارثه اللي هتقضي علينا دي
ده كان لسان حال مؤسسي جوجل لاري بيج
وسيرج برين والرئيس التنفيذي للشركه
ووجهها الشهير ايريك شميت لما عرفوا
بالضربه القاضيه اللي ضربتها لهم
مايكروسوفت سنه 2006 وقتها مايكروسوفت
اللي هي صاحبه اكبر نظام مستخدم على اجهزه
الكمبيوتر اللي هو ويندوز بنسخه كانت لسه
خارجه من الحرب القضائيه الشرسه اللي
خضتها ضد الحكومه الامريكيه من
1998 ل 2001 ايوه زي ما سمعتم كده حرب ضد
حكومه نفس بلد الشركه الام للي ما يعرفش
من حضراتكم امريكا عندها قانون مشهور اسمه
قانون منع الاحتكار ده تشريع الهدف منه
باختصار منع اي شركه من انها تكبر زياده
عن اللازم لحد ما تبقى كيان بيسيطر على
السوق ومش سايب مساحه لاي منافس انه حتى
يتنفس مايكروسوفت في اواخر التسعينات كانت
في طريقها لده والطريقه اللي بتدمر بها
منافسيها والمنظومه اللي عملها بيل جيتس
قلقت الامريكيين جدا وكانت القشه بالنسبه
للحكومه هي محاوله مايكروسوفت افشال نت
سكيب اشهر متصفح في العالم وقتها
فوزارة لكن دي مش الحقيقه كامله في جزء
مهم بيميل بعض الناس لتجاهله وهو ان
مايكروسوفت بعد المحاكمه ما بقتش زي الاول
على الاقل واللي حصل اثر عليها فعلا وقلل
من هيمنتها على السوق لان ده ببساطه اتسبب
في تشتيتها وبالتالي سمح لشركات ثانيه
بالصعود زي ابل وزي جوجل اللي كانت لسه
طالعه مايكروسوفت بقى ماتعلمتش من الدرس
وفي 2006 قررت تضرب جوجل في مقتل وخل بينج
هو محرك البحث الافتراضي على متصفحها
انترنت اكسبلورر طب ليه دي خطوه تدميريه
لجوجل علشان في الوقت ده انترنت اكسبلورر
اللي بنضحك عليه دلوقتي وما بقاش موجود
كان هو المتصفح الاساسي على كل جهاز
كمبيوتر تقريبا
فخطوط الاحتياط وهيموت في الوقت ده كان في
مهندس هندي شاب ذكي جدا لسه داخل جوجل
جديد قال لهم يا جماعه احنا تاعبين نفسنا
ليه اجهزه الحاسب مكونه من جزئين سوفت وير
وده بهاي من عليه مايكروسوفت وقفله الباب
قدامنا بالضبه والمفتاح وجزء ثاني اللي هو
الهارد وير احنا نسيب مايكروسوفت خالص
ونروح لمصنعي الاجهزه نفسهم ونخليهم
يضيفوا جوجل تول بار لنسخه واللي فيه محرك
البحث بتاعنا على اجهزتهم مباشره عن طريق
ما يسمى بالبري انستول سوفت وير او
البرامج المثبته مسبقا ولان الشاب ده
عبقري وقار المستقبل فقدر يقنع مسؤولي
جوجل انهم يستثمروا كمان في تطوير متصفح
خاص بهم ينافس انترنت اكسبلورر ويمكن
بعدين يقدر ينافسه ويزحف وبالفعل جوجل
نفذت المقترحات العبقريه دي والاجهزه بقى
فيها محرك البحث جوجل رغم انف مايكروسوفت
ومش بس كده بعدها بسنتين وتحديدا في 2008
ظهرت للنور اول نسخه من جوجل كروم وبقيت
الحكايه ونجاح جوجل الساحق ومنتجاتها
معروف لحد اللحظه المهندس الزكي ده اسمه
سوندر بشاي تلف الايام ويتعين سوندر بشاي
رئيس تنفيذ الجوجل في 2015 ودلوقتي بيقف
نفس وقفه بيل جيتس من 25 سنه تقريبا في وش
الطوفان امام الجهات التنظيميه الامريكيه
يوم الثلاث 12 سبتمبر اللي فات وبعد اسبوع
من احتفال جوجل بعيد ميلادها ال 25 اتعملت
اول جلسه في قضيه مكافحه الاحتكار اللي
رفعها وزاره العدل على الشركه الم الحكمه
دي يا اخوانا هي ابرز قضيه مكافحه احتكار
في مجال التقنيه من ساعه قضيه مايكروسوفت
وعدد من المسؤولين والمحللين بيعتبروها
بدايه خطه حكوميه امريكيه لمقاضاته
التقنيه الخامسه في امريكا واللي هم
الفابيت ومعاها امازون وابل ومايكروسوفت
ومتا وهنعرف ليه في الحلقه ان توقعاتهم
غالبا صح باختصار ممكن نسميها محاكمه
القرن ال 21 حتى الان مش هنكون بنبال
الكلام ده يخلي لنا نسال شويه اسئله مهمه
جدا زي مثلا ايه اللي خلى وزاره العدل
الامريكيه تنشن اسلحتها على جوجل وايه هو
السيناريو الخطير اللي جوجل بتدفع مليارات
كل سنه لشركه ابل علشان تتجنبه وهل اللي
بيحصل ده ممكن ياثر على شكل الانترنت اللي
بنستخدمه يوميا وهل في خطر اكبر من القضيه
دي بتواجهه جوجل ده جزء من الاسئله
المثيره اللي هندرس فيها مع بعض في حلقه
النهارده بس قبل ما نبدا بفكركم بالاشتراك
في القناه لان اشتراككم مهم جدا لتطوير
القناه واستمرارنا في تقديم محتوانا انا
اشرف ابراهيم ده المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي عايز اشكر شركه اكسنس العالميه
لرعايتها الحلقه دي وهي شركه عندها خبره
طويله في الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات
شهريه تجاوز ال 2 ترليون دولار ليه بانصح
بالتعامل مع اكسنس علشان اربع مميزات
الاولى انها مرخصه ومراقبه من هيئات
رقابيه الثانيه بعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها بشكل
فوري بدون تدخل بشري الثالثه ان عمتهم
منخفضه الرابعه ان التداول بيتنفذ بسرعه
تقدر تفتح حساب اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا
تشتري وتبيع الاسهم والدهب هتلاقوا لينك
ليهم تحت الفيديو وفي تعليقات
فيسبوك actually have to morea people
more year than many people do
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جوجل زي ما كلنا عارفين هي الشركه اللي
بتصنع اكثر منتجات برمجيه مشهوره في
العالم الحاجات اللي انا وحضراتكم
بنستعملها كل يوم كتير جدا زي محرك البحث
جوجل اللي بيسيطر سيطره شبه كامله على
عمليات البحث على شبكه الانترنت وجوجل
كروم الم صفح الاشهر على الاطلاق وطبعا
يوتيوب اللي بتشوفوني عليه دلوقتي حالا
منصه الفيديو الاكبر عالميه وحتى النسخه
الافضل والاشهر من نظام اندرويد واللي على
موبايلات عدد كتير منكم برض جوجل اللي
طورتها فاحنا نقدر نقول من غير اي مبالغه
انه ما فيش انسان على وش الارض بيستخدم
الانترنت باي شكل ما بيستعمل او ماستعمل
منتج من منتجات الشركه سواء زمان او
دلوقتي والمنتجات دي وغيرها من منتجات
الشركه هي اللي مهيمنه على السوق هيمنه
شبه كامله وده اللي بتقوله باختصار
الحكومه الفيدراليه الامريكيه من خلال
القضيه اللي رفعاها دي بيقولوا يا جماعه
كفايه كده لان القوه الاحتكاريه اللي
عندكم دي بتديك ميزات غير عادله خالص قدام
السوق كله يعني الشركه بتعالج حوالي 90%
من جميع عمليات البحث عبر الانترنت في
امريكا لوحدها متخيلين النسبه هيمنه شبه
مطلقه وتطبيق بالحرف الواحد لجمله اسال
جوجل وعلشان كده الهيمنه دي اللي هي اساس
ايرادات جوجل الضخمه من الاعلانات هي
المحرك الرئيسي لايرادات الفابيت بالكامل
وهي اللي خلت قيمتها السوقيه تعدي ال 1.6
ترليون دولار حاليه لو بصينا مثلا على
ايرادات جوجل السنه اللي فاتت بس 2022
هنلاقي ان الشركه عامله اجمالي ايرادات
وصل ل 280 مليار دولار تقريبا الاعلانات
في اي مكان وموقع تابع لجوجل هي اللي لها
نصيب الاسد من الايرادات دي برقم وصل ل
224 وص مليار دولار منهم 162 ونص ايرادات
من محرك البحث وحوالي 29 مليار من اعلانات
اليوتيوب والارقام دي على سبيل المثال
للحصر بتوضح لحضراتكم ازاي جوجل مهيمنه
على عمليات البحث والاعلانات بالنسبه اللي
قلتها لكم دي علشان كده الجماعه في وزاره
العدل بيقولوا من خلال القضيه انه يا
اخوانا ما ينفعش شركه ايا كانت مين وبتعمل
ايه تسيطر على س ما بالنسبه الخرافيه دي
ده كلامهم بس الحقيقه ان الموضوع مش وليد
اللحظه يعني المدعي العام الامريكي مصحيش
من النوم قال ايه الزهق اللي انا فيه ده
يلا بينا نرفع قضيه على جوجل الموضوع ليه
خلفيات اكبر من كده دي مش المره الاولى
اللي جوجل بتواجه فيها اسئله وقضايا
وغرامات فيما يخص الهيمنه بتاعتها لو
رجعنا بالوقت شويه لسنه 2011 هلاقي ان
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه اف تي سي واللي
مهمتها الاساسيه كوكال حكوميه امريكيه هي
مراقبه تنفيذ قانون مكافحه الاحتكار كانت
فتحت تحقيق بيحاول يتاكد من مزاعم ان جوجل
بتخالف شروط اتفاقيه مستخدم متصفح سفاري
متصفح اجهزه شركه ابل وانها من خلال
المخالفات دي بتزرع ملفات نشاطات
المستخدمين اللي هي الكوكيز او الملفات
اللي بتعرف اي متصفح والشركه اللي وراه
انت زرت ايه وامتى في متصفح سفاري
وبتستخدم في انها توريهم اعلانات موجهه
التحقيق ده مر لسنتين لحد 2013 وخلص
بتسويه قضائيه وبغرامه وصلت ل 22.5 مليون
دولار والغرامه دي رغم انها الاكبر في
تاريخ الاف تي سي وقتها لاي قضيه متعلقه
باختراق الخصوصيه على الانترنت الا انها
غرامه طبعا ما تساويش ذره في ايرادات جوجل
اللي تعدت 55 وص مليار دولار في 2013 لو
جينا للحق في امريكا من وجهه نظر مشرعي
القوانين ايدها خفيفه شويه على جوجل
والشركات الك كبر عموما وقوانين مكافحه
الاحتكار بتاعتها لحد وقت قريب جدا ما
كانتش بتطبق
بالصرافه بالنسبه للمشرعين دول
والاوروبيين في نظرهم بيمارسوا سيطره افضل
على الشركات العملاقه عموما علشان كده
هنلاقي ان اكبر مبالغ اغرمت جوجل هي في
اوروبا بسبب تطبيق قوانينهم الصارمه جدا
مقارنه بنظراتها الامريكيه فيما يخص حمايه
البيانات علشان تعرفوا الاوروبيين بيعملوا
ايه في جوجل خليني اقول لكم انه في الش
سنين الاخيره محاكم الاتحاد الاوروبي غرمت
الشركه مبالغ مجموعها وصل ل 8.2 مليار
يورو الغرامات دي اتفرضت نتيجه لثلاث
تحقيقات ضخمه على مدار ال سنين دول واللي
عاوزين نركز عليه هنا هو الغرامه الكبيره
اللي اتفرضت على الشركه سنه 2018 بسبب
استغلالها لنظام اندرويد في تعزيز هيمنتها
على عمليات البحث والاعلانات الغرامه دي
يا اخوانا وصلت ل 4.1 مليار يورو وجوجل
طعنت على الحكم لكن المحكمه العامه
للاتحاد الاوروبي في سبتمبر 2022 رفضت
الطعن وحاليا جوجل قدامها فرصه واحده بس
لالغاء الغرامه او تقليلها وهتكون قدام
محكمه العدل الاوروبيه اعلى محكمه في
اوروبا اللي هتصدر حكمها النهائي اوائل
السنه الجايه 2024 الناكسه دي كانت المره
الثانيه اللي جوجل تخسر فيها طعن على
غرامه ضخمه كده والمره الاولى كانت قبلها
بسنه واحده بس في نوفمبر 2021 وساعتها
المحكمه العامه اكدت غرامه قدرها 2.4
مليار يورو
فوزارة 20 اكتوبر 2020 وزاره العدل رفعت
ملف القضيه اللي احنا شايفينها حاليا ملف
مكون من 64 صفحه بتزعم في الوزاره ان جوجل
بدات بتنفيذ خططها واحتكار السوق من 2010
وانها في السنين اللي فاتت خلت محرك البحث
الخاص بها هو المحرك الافتراضي على مجموعه
متنوعه وواسعه جدا من الاجهزه والمنصات
المختلفه ورتبت الوضع علشان محرك جوجل
يظهر بشكل بارز على الهواتف المحموله
واجهزه كمبيوتر الشركه قدرت تعمل ده بحسب
اتهامات وزاره العدل من خلال صرف عشرات
مليارات من الدولارات كل سنه لاستبعاد
المنافسين من الاماكن المهمه زي شركات
تصنيع الهواتف المحموله ومطوري متصفحات
الانترنت الاشهر وقدرت تستبعده عن طريق
توقيع عقود شبهه حصريه مع الشركات الكبرى
زي ابل وسامسونج وموتورولا وبعض اهم شركات
الاتصالات وقائمه قائمه طويله من اهم
الشركات في امريكا وفي العالم على سبيل
المثال هنلاقي ان وزاره العدل لقت ان جوجل
بتدفع في السنه الابل حوالي 12 مليار
دولار مقابل ان ابل اللي هي اكبر بائع
للهواتف المحموله في العالم ومن اكبر بائع
الحواسيب والاجهزه الاخرى تخلي محرك بحث
جوجل هو المحرك الافتراضي اللي بتظهر ابل
في اجهزتها لمستخدميها بشكل اساسي يعني
علشان تتخيلوا الصوره ففي حال في العالم
اكث من 2 مليار جهاز مختلف من منتجات ابل
بس معظمهم تليفونات ايفون وكمبيوترات
مختلفه على الاجهزه دي كلها هنلاقي منتج
جوجل الاهم اللي هو محرك البحث موجود على
الانظمه اللي بتشغلها كمحرك اساسي وزاره
العدل بتقول ان حوالي نص حركه البحث
تقريبا على جوجل بتيجي من اجهزه ابل ابل
تحديدا هي اهم واخطر اتفاقات جوجل وحجر
الزاويه لايرادات الشركه زي ما شفنا وفرصه
ممتازه لجوجل لفرد نفسها في مساحه واسعه
جدا عالميه علشان كده سوندر بيتشاي من
ساعه ما بقى سي جوجل في
2015 هو شايف ان ابل مساحه ما ينفعش حد
يهزر معاهم فيها حتى ابل نفسها اللي لما
حاولت تعترض على بعض بنود الاتفاقيه جوجل
هددتها بتقليص مدفوعاتها من الاعلانات
بتشاي قابل تيم كوك رئيس التنفيذ الابل
اكثر من مره بالمناسبه اشهرهم في 2017
و28 علشان يعززوا التعاون ما بينهم لكن
المقابله اللي بتركز عليها وزاره العدل
الامريكيه كانت في 2018 وفقا لاوراق
الدعوه القضائيه بتاعه 2020 بتشاي ابل كوك
علشان يجاوبوا مع بعض على سؤال واحد اساسي
ازاي نزود ارادتنا وارباح السنويه مع بعض
طبعا ده سؤال مهم جدا ليه لاننا ببساطه
بنتكلم عن اجتماع اكبر واهم شركتين
تقنيتين في العالم تقريبا فتخيلوا القوه
الاقتصاديه المهوله دي اللي هي بحجم
اقتصاد لوكش دول مع بعض ممكن تعمل ايه بعد
الاجتماع ده وزاره العدل بتقول ان واحد من
اللي شغالين في ابل بعت لحد في جوجل وقال
له ان رؤيتنا هي ان نعمل كما لو كنا شركه
واحده لكن وزاره العدل لسه ما قالتش مين
دول بالظبط لحد وقت تصوير الحلقه علشان ده
كله اكت جوجل شايفه ان عقدها مع ابل مهم
وخطير جدا لدرجه انها بتعتبر خساره عقد زي
ده او تغيير بنوده الاساسيه هو جرس انذار
ضخم احمر او كود ريد سيناريو كارثي ما
ينفعش ابدا تتعرض له باي شكل تخيلوا بقى
لو حطينا كل حوار ابل ده جنب امتلاك شركه
جوجل لنسخه نظام اندرويد اللي معظم
مستخدمي النظام بيستخدموها مع امتلاك
الشركه لجوجل نفسه كمحرك بحث والكروم
كمتصفح واليوتيوب كمنص مشاهده وهيمنتها
على سوق الاعلانات الرقمي وضربنا كل ده في
الخلاط
تفتكروا يطلع لنا ايه بالظبط كده شركه حطه
شبكه الانترنت كلها في جيبها الصغير ده في
نظر وزاره العدل التابعه لاداره ترامب خلى
المنافسه مستحيله على اي شركه ايا كانت هي
مين ومعاها فلوس قد ايه لكن الاهم في
القضيه من ساعه ما بدات انها لقت اجماع
سياسي نادر جدا جدا نلاقيه في امريكا من
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين مع بعض اجماع
على عمليه صيد جوجل دي طب كل ده وماعرفناش
موقف جوجل من اللي بيحصل جوجل قالت ايه
بقى لو مشينا ورا تصريحات الشركه على
السنه مختلف ممثليها الاعلاميين وفرقها
القانونيه في السنين اللي فاتت هنلاقي
تصريحاتها تقريبا ما بتتغيرش فممكن نلخصها
ببساطه كده في ان الشركه بتوصف القضايا
بانها قضايا معيبه ومسؤوليها حاسين بخيبه
امل شديده حد تعبيرهم بسبب الغرامات
الاوروبيه المتتاليه ومحاوله وزاره العدل
امريكيه مقاضاتهم وشايفين ان اللي بيحصل
ده هو محاوله لدفع الناس لاستخدام منتجات
اقل جوده من كل النواحي علشان بس يتقال ان
في اختيارات اهو قدامكم كمستهلكين رغم ان
الاختيارات دي هي اختيارات رديئه وهتضرب
المستخدم وتجربته وهترفع اسعار التليفونات
وغيرها طبعا ده كلام مش فارق نهائيا مع
الجيل الحالي من محامين وزاره العدل اللي
عاوزين يعملوا حمله على شركات التقنيه
الكبر وعلى راسهم الراجل اللي هتشوفوه
واقف دايما مباشره ورا ميري جارلند المدعي
العام الامريكي ده جونسن كانتور يا جماعه
مساعد المدعي العام الامريكي لمكافحه
الاحتكار هو رئيس قسم مكافحه الاحتكار
والشخص اللي مركز مع جوجل بقى له شهور
الحقيقه دي مش اول قضيه لكتر ضد جوجل
كانتر فتح القضيه الحاليه اللي ورثها من
اداره ترامب لكن رفع قضيه ثانيه ضد احتكار
جوجل للاعلانات الرقميه وانتشارها وواضح
انه مش هيسيب جوجل في حالها خالص الكلام
ده ما ينطبق على جوناثان لوحده وانما على
جيل كامل من المحامين الحكوميين
الامريكيين اللي الظاهر انهم حاطين في
دماغهم شركات التقنيه الكبرى الامريكيه
وده طبعا واضح جدا فاكرين لما سالتكم في
اول الحلقه هل اداره بايدن هتكت بجوجل ولا
هتمد ايدها على حد ثاني من عمالقه
التكنولوجيا الخامسه في امريكا من اقل من
اسبوعين يوم 26 سبتمبر اللي فات لجنه
الجاره الفيدراليه الامريكيه وعلى راسها
رئيسه اللجنه ونجمته الصاعده لينا خان
بدات مقاضاه عملاق التجاره الالكترونيه
الاهم في العالم شركه امازون لدواعي
احتكار خدمات التسويق الالكتروني واضعاف
المنافسين واضح انه مش جوجل بس اللي
ايامها الجايه هتبقى مش فايته لكن لو
جيتوا للحق فجوجل محتاجه تركز في خطر اكبر
قدامها من خطر قضايا الحكومه الامريكيه
ضدها والخطر ده هو عدو قديم جديد مرعب
اسمه مايكروسوفت مسؤولي جوجل حاليا يا
اخوانا بيمروا بفتره مش مريحه بعد الصعود
الصاروخي لشركه اوبن اي اي الشركه الملكه
والمطوره لاشهر نموذج لغوي كبير هو شد جي
بي تي واللي مايكروسوفت تعتبر المستثمر
الاكبر فيها حد هيسال ني ايه علاقه شج بي
تي بجوجل يا اشرف هقول لك مايكروسوفت
حاليا وبعد النجاح الساحق لشد جي بي تي في
تغيير انماط البحث التقليديه عندنا
كمستخدم انترنت بتحاول تصحي من النوم محرك
البحث بتاعها بينج فاكرينه ايوه بالظبط هو
المحرك اللي حاولت تقتل بيه جوجل من 17
سنه اهو مايكروسوفت حاليا هتطور بينج بشكل
شامل وهتديني البحث العميق والذكاء
الاصطناعي الخاصه بشد ج بي تي طبعا ده
عامل رعب لجوجل اللي محركها بالفعل بدا
يتاثر بشكل خفيف يعني انت او انا عندنا
سؤال لحد سنتين ثلاثه فاتوا ما كانش حد
فينا يتصور اي حاجه غير اننا هندخل على
جوجل نلط على السؤال ونشوف هنوصل لايه
دلوقتي بقى عندنا روبوت مزود بقاعده
بيانات رهيبه بيجاوب على معظم اسئلتنا
الشائعه بشكل مباشر تماما وبوضوح تام
بيجمع لك كل مكونات الطبخه ويطبخ لك ويقدم
لك الاكل التغير ده في تعاملنا مع البحث
على الانترنت مع الاستثمارات المهوله
بتاعه مايكروسوفت اللي ضخت 10 مليار دولار
السنه دي 2023 في اوبن اي اي عمل ربكه في
جوجل اللي بتحاول تسارع في تقديم نموذجها
اللغوي المزود بالذكاء الاصطناعي الخاص
بها وبتحاول تطوره وتدمج في محرك بحثها
علشان تلحق الموضوع من اوله لكن جوجل هنا
عندها ميزه مهمه جدا الانترنت لحد اللحظه
لسه بتاعها مجازا يعني زي ما شرحت لكم فده
بيديها دايما سابقه على المنافسين وده مش
كلامي لوحدي ده كلام وزاره العدل
الامريكيه برده ولكن رغم كده فمتوقع ان
جوجل تقضي الكام سنه الجايين في القتال
امام الجهات التنظيميه الامريكيه
والاوروبيه لحمايه الامبراطوريه العالميه
اللي بنتها على مدار ال 25 سنه اللي فاتوا
لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي علشان ماطولش على
حضراتكم وكالعاده عندي سؤال ليكم تفتكروا
جوجل هتنو من الحرب المزوجه دي ضد الحكومه
الامريكيه ومايكروسوفت في نفس الوقت
وهتعرف تقاوم ولا هنشوف سيناريو شبه خيالي
هتنت في جوجل في المستقبل اتابع كل
اجاباتكم في التعليقات ما تنسوش تشتركوا
في القناه زي ما اتفقنا لي عايز يشتري
اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس
هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ويا ريت لو
عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير واهم حاجه
تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
يستفيدوا
[موسيقى]
سلام